and if there isn't enough going on in
politics Democratic presidential
candidates will hold their sixth debate
tonight in Los Angeles ed O'Keefe is
there Edie we expect to hear much about
impeachment tonight oh very likely you
know campaign 2020 will be the first
where a challenger is running against an
incumbent impeached president and here
in Los Angeles tonight we're going to
see fewer candidates on stage than we've
seen in the past just seven of them have
qualified this will be the first debate
where there isn't a black or Latino
candidate on stage that's because
candidates like Cory Booker and who leon
castro failed to meet the polling and
fundraising thresholds the candidates
who are on stage tonight as we said are
likely to get questions about the
impeachment vote but also about other
issues more directly affecting the
voters that's in part because voting her
polling has shown that Democrats
overwhelmingly support impeaching the
president but also want to hear about
how they would defeat him
next November meanwhile we spoke with
voters across the country yesterday
ahead of the impeachment vote as you
might expect the opinions were varied
take a listen it's time that you felt
accountable he's not above the
Constitution I see this whole thing
a distraction so the president to get
things done on the world stage and you
think it he had it come in but I don't
think it was politically a smart move
completely 100 percent boat he will be
vindicated now the impeachment trial
could take five of the presidential
candidates who are also senators off the
campaign trail for a few weeks as they
sit as jurors in that impeachment trial
they're all vowing to attend but that
means other candidates who aren't in the
center like Joe Biden or Pete Buddha
judge might have Iowa New Hampshire all
to themselves for a few weeks a
potentially big advantage Tony all right
thank you very much